resuelve la ecuación y determinar los
valores excluidos los valores excluidos
son aquellos valores de p que hacen que
algún lado de la igualdad quede
indefinido y es importante encontrarlos
porque mientras manipulamos la expresión
para resolver esta ecuación es posible
que perdamos información acerca de los
denominadores de cuando no podemos
dividir entre cierta cosa al final puede
ser que encontremos alguna solución pero
si esa solución coincide con algunos de
los valores excluidos entonces tenemos
que descartarlo bueno entonces pues
vamos a calcular los valores excluidos
empecemos con el lado izquierdo esta
expresión queda indefinida cuando
dividimos entre 0 es decir cuando p
menos uno es igual a cero o bien cuando
p es igual a uno déjame escribir esto
por acá entonces p tiene que ser
distinto distinto de uno para evitar la
división entre cero aquí de manera
similar al lado derecho
tenemos que esto queda indefinido si
dividimos entre cero o sea cuando p más
3 es igual a 0 o bien cuando p es igual
a menos 3 entonces también tenemos que
cuidar
que pese a distinto de -3 y listo estos
de acá 1 y menos 3 son nuestros valores
excluidos vale bueno ya que tenemos esto
en mente podemos trabajar con esta
expresión pensando que no es ni uno ni
menos tres así que ahora sí podemos
intentar pues deshacernos de estos
denominadores multiplicando por p menos
uno y por p más tres déjame volver a
escribir la la ecuación para tener un
poco más de espacio entonces tenemos 4
entre p menos uno igual a 5 5 entre p
más 3 entonces para deshacernos de este
denominador p - 1 podemos multiplicar
por p menos uno de este lado pero como
es una igualdad también tenemos que
multiplicar por p menos uno de este otro
para que no perdamos la igualdad vale de
manera similar vamos a querer eliminar
este p más tres así que hay que
multiplicar aquí por p más 3 pero para
compensarlo del otro lado también aquí
hay que multiplicar por p +3 ahora sí
vamos a ver cuánto nos queda este p
menos uno se cancela con este este tema
con este tema 3 aquí a la izquierda nos
queda 4 por 3 y distribuyendo este 4 en
estos dos suman 2 nos queda al lado
izquierdo 4 p más 12 4 p
y eso es igual a a ver qué sucede en el
lado derecho este se canceló con este
hay que multiplicar este 5 por estos dos
suman 2 nos queda 5 p 5 p menos 5 y
estaré aquí ya es una ecuación lineal de
las sencillas vamos a resolverla
queremos pasar todas las constantes de
un lado y todas las del otro así que
déjame pasar este 4 p a la derecha es
decir tengo que restar 4 p de ambos
lados aquí voy a restar menos 4 p y aquí
también menos 4 p para preservar la
igualdad entonces qué nos queda nos
queda este se cancela con este aquí nos
queda 5 p menos 4 p esp menos 5 es igual
a 12 y finalmente podemos sumar 5 de
ambos lados sumamos 5 aquí y sumamos 5
acá más 5 de tal forma que éste se
cancela con este y nos queda que p es 12
o sea que p es igual a 17 muy bien p es
igual a 17 observemos que p no es
ninguno de nuestros valores excluidos
así que todo va muy bien pero
para verificar que hicimos todo
correctamente vamos a sustituir en esta
igualdad para ver si se cumple que p
solución entonces déjame tomar este
color y vamos a ver qué sucede si
ponemos 17 entonces 4 entre 17 menos uno
tiene que ser igual a 5 entre 17 3 o sea
nos gustaría que 4 entre 16 fuera igual
a 5 entre 20 2004 entre 16 es lo mismo
que que 1
cuarto y 5 entre 20 también es un cuarto
también es un cuarto entonces esto
termina la verificación y por lo tanto
la solución de esta ecuación es p igual
a 17